the first time i saw this
house was probably about march of
2005 i was thinking it was the perfect
house to raise
a family in it had
four bedrooms it had a yard
but what sold me the most was the
kitchen the kitchen was so nice and
spacious
after spending years saving up to buy a
home
by 2005 delicia scott you know had saved
up enough money
to buy a modest two-story english tutor
for about 63
000 after losing her job in the great
recession
she fell behind on her property taxes
and her home was foreclosed on
by the county and sold at auction for
about forty six hundred dollars
[Music]
but here's the thing dilecia scott never
should have lost
her home and the reason is the city of
detroit
for years was overvaluing her property
so that she paid thousands of dollars
more in taxes
than what she owed and it's not just
dylecia
and it's not just detroit this is a
pattern
that we're seeing all over the country
county by county city by city where
black homeowners
their properties being overvalued and
thus over taxed and in the most extreme
cases
many of those people end up losing their
homes
i know i'm not the only person in the
city in detroit that's living in the
house that they used to own that they're
still running because
they just don't want to leave their
house or they don't want to miss the
opportunity of purchasing their house
back
i feel it's a travesty
the property tax is the largest source
of local revenue
for cities counties school districts
it raises more than 500 billion dollars
a year across the country
paying for you know public safety
sanitation
schools all of the basic services that
local governments provide
it's the foundation of our local systems
so the property tax is actually a pretty
complicated tax because
unlike say a sales tax or an income tax
where we have data for each individual
sale or each individual person's income
and with respect to the property tax
only maybe two or three percent of homes
will sell in a year
and that means for the vast majority of
homes there's no
real time indication of their value and
that's the job of the assessor is
to figure out the value for all the
homes including the many
that didn't sell and the way that's done
is by looking at the homes that have
sold trying to build a statistical model
that relates the price of those homes
to their features and characteristics
and applying it to all the homes
in order to get prices for the homes
that haven't sold
and essentially what they do is they
they take the prices of these properties
and figure out well how much per square
foot
how how much per bathroom and they have
some other variables like location and
other things they do
but it's all sort of observable
characteristics of the homes
from the outside
the problem comes up with what assessors
cannot see
some people may have redone their
kitchen
or upgraded their bathroom other people
may have a leaky roof
or a porch that's falling down or a
missing window
these are characteristics of the house
that assessors cannot see
and what research is shown is that it
adds
variability at the lower end of the
price scale
and so makes those homes particularly
difficult
to value and so if the valuations if
that is
skewed in some way then you're going to
have the same kind of
issues with the bills themselves it's
sort of you know garbage in
garbage out
the biggest problem that i've been
focused on
is this issue that we call regressivity
and this is the phenomenon that
homes that have a low price tend to be
assessed at
a higher level relative to their true
price
than our homes that sell at high prices
which is just to say
low priced homes tend to have an
assessment level
of usually over 100 of their value in
other words they're being assessed
at more than what they're actually worth
whereas high-priced homes
are often assessed at less than what
they're actually worth
and what that means is that low-valued
homes are paying more than they should
in taxes
and high-valued homes are paying less
than they should in taxes because
the assessment is the basis for
determining the tax
and what that means is because
black people own the lowest valued homes
disproportionately
and because the lowest valued homes are
overtaxed this problem of regressivity
actually becomes a structural or
institutional
racism problem because it's
disproportionately impacting
black people and disproportionately
helping white people
contributing to the racial wealth gap
it's a very important piece of the
systemic racism
puzzle and just to give you a kind of a
measurement of how bad this can be
in chicago alone there's been a study
that showed
in just five years 2.2
billion dollars in property taxes and
the burden of property taxes
was shifted from the highest valued
homes to the lowest
[Music]
i first saw this in chicago and anyone
from chicago will tell you
i mean chicago is just kind of a special
place
my first reaction was well this is you
know one of those only in chicago
sort of things it really only began to
dawn on me after that chicago work began
to get attention
i started hearing from people in other
places and
ultimately that led me to want to know
are there just some peculiar places
where this is a problem or is this
really fundamental and the more data i
got and the more places
i looked the more i could see that this
is just baked in
deeply to the property tax and it is
very pervasive it's not only in chicago
it's not only in detroit it's virtually
everywhere that i've looked
a recent study by the university of
chicago
looked at 2600 counties across the
united states
and found this pattern was pervasive
more than nine out of ten
of these jurisdictions had this
regressivity problem
and there's no place where this tragedy
isn't playing out more than in detroit
one in four properties in detroit have
been foreclosed on because they fell
behind on their taxes
[Music]
for the person that owned this house
it's a tool to make money
i want to take you on a journey of what
it's like for me when i have to pay my
rent every month
if i drop it off myself i drive here i
know i get here
so no one can say well we didn't get
your payment or whatever
for me it's where i raised my kids at
this is
the the stability that i was able to
give them
that i didn't really have as a child so
here's the process
so you see there's no dropbox outside
no mail slot in the doorway so what i
usually do
this nice little welcome back
usually slide it
from the side make sure they go further
enough
into the building so nobody has the
opportunity to try to fish it out
so when i had kids i wanted to make
in my mission that they didn't have to
have those experiences i didn't want
them to have to worry about
where we have to lay our head or or
is it going to be safe for us that is my
meal
and i feel like that may be further
enough somebody try to fish it out they
don't have to work for it
i want to leave my children something
they've seen their mother
work all their lives yeah i got
insurance policies
but you know that's not nothing like
having a home i want to leave them
something that i worked hard for
that i earned and i put my blood sweat
and tears into
hopefully it's as you know it's they
finna get to where it
needs to go i don't want the threat of
somebody can come in and displace
me even if i pay my rent on time
somebody
can come in and say like you know what
thanks but no thanks
in america owning property is
the you know if not the one of the most
um significant drivers of wealth i mean
they don't call it the american dream
for nothing and part of the american
dream is owning a home
it doesn't just benefit your current
economic situation
it really has an impact over
generations the way the rubber meets the
road here
is that families that are trying to
accumulate and build wealth
with property which is how you build
wealth in america
are being over taxed because the homes
that they buy are on the lower end of
the price scale
some would argue that they also suffer
from lack of services
police schools aren't as good all of
these other things
and so it's not just a matter of how
much
in taxes people pay but what they're
paying for
it it sort of skews the entire system in
a way that that's just deeply unfair
this pattern of unfairness it doesn't
happen in a vacuum
there's a long history in the u.s of of
racial segregation
redlining whereby black families were
kept out of the highest
valued neighborhoods
in my view this is a textbook example of
institutional racism because you know
institutional racism i think of that as
a system in which
the outcomes are disproportionately
unfavorable
to a minority group even though no
actor in the system may necessarily be
motivated by racial animus and i'm
certainly not claiming that assessors
are individually racist that's not
the takeaway at all but rather the
system
produces racially disparate outcomes
even though
or even if no individual person involved
in it
intends it to be that way
this falls in a category of hardships
that i
think are in the everyday experience of
african americans
that aren't always recognized until they
are documented with data
because the people in power would not
like to recognize them
the truth is even with that sort of
evidence the system is not quick
to respond either i'm familiar with
professor barry and his colleagues and i
have a fundamental disagreement with
with that statement
we have reviewed every single sale in
the city over 65 000 over a 24-month
period
so that you know there seems to be a
pattern among local officials
when these issues are pointed out to
them so for example in chicago
the assessors attacked professor barry
personally
they attacked me personally when chris
did similar studies in detroit
the same thing happened they said you
know he's a right-wing provocateur who
doesn't want high taxes they said he
can't value the property from chicago
that it's not all about spreadsheets
that somehow these
very statistically driven processes are
an art form
and not you know based on numbers a very
smart person once told me this it's an
art not a science
you have the facts but you also have to
understand the market
detroit is a unique market and you can't
you can't
get those nuances simply from a sales
study
you have to live here and you have to
understand what's going on here
to understand evaluation the real
tragedy in cases like delicia's
is that there are other people who are
benefiting off the system
in detroit for example delecia's home
was one of
thousands that was put up for auction uh
in 2014
and so that sort of flooded the market
with very you know
foreclosed homes which are very cheap
that investors you know come in and
and scoop up and then rent back to
people or just hold his assets on their
balance sheet
in addition to that the county
government for detroit wayne county
takes these delinquent taxes and is able
to roll them up
into bonds so it's sort of i call it a
perpetual money
machine where some people wealth is
destroyed
and there's others who the wealth is
created
to fix this problem is going to require
a lot more resources
and assessment offices just don't have
that so it's better to stick your head
in the ground
and and try to act like there's nothing
there of course you can't fix the
problem
if you don't admit that you have a
problem
i think the hardest question here is
how do you fix the system or at least
how do you improve it
my thinking is that the system can be
improved but i'm not sure it can be
completely
fixed and the reason i say that is
because this problem of those
unobservable
features of homes those things that
buyers and sellers get to see but the
assessor doesn't get to see
that's a pretty fundamental problem the
assessor can improve things by
using better statistical models by
getting better data but i think there's
there's just fundamentally an upper
bound towards how
fair the system can be and so we should
really be asking ourselves is
you know how much unfairness are we
willing to tolerate
as a society it's hard to get more
personal than someone's home
and so these taxes on on people's homes
it touches everyone's life it seems like
this arcane
sort of boring corner of municipal
finance
but in fact it's it's really how people
live their lives
and how people gain wealth and provide
for their families
i'm not on the lease so now you know
it's scary because again they could come
in and say
you you gotta leave so the roof has been
leaking
there's mold in the basement we just
live around it because
at the end of the day this is my home
even though somebody
profits for it even though this home is
going to
give somebody else's children financial
wealth
my kids are not going to benefit for
from my hard labor
my hard work and the money that we put
into it
it's still my home at the end of the day
[Music]
[Music]
you